Pewdepie is a big old meanie, Logan Paul...
defends himself and much more information coming up.
I'm Poppy Harlow and you're watching pew news (weird pop thing)
Good Evening. I'm poppy Harlow you're watching pew news the most
...new site. As you may have heard PewDiePie got into trouble in the media recently (clears throat)
I hate that Guy
I don't even care that it was a deep-fried meme.
The fact that he posted it speaks volumes.
I feel like I'm probably better off not talking about this, but I want to share my thoughts. I didn't know much about Demi I...
I've only really just played her video game a few years ago, and I realized that...uh..
It's for kids. She clearly has a very very young audience me to see that she's messing with drugs...
I just thought what an idiot. I'm not the greatest role model, but at least I've never done anything
Straight-out illegal, so I thought well, you know, it's just fun to make- fine to just make fun of it and I realized now
No, no, it wasn't because a lot of people seem to doubt my sincerity
I guess in some way. Just to give context it was 5 a.m. in the morning. Sometimes my dogs wake me up really early and uhh
This has nothing to do with anything.
Basically, I saw the meme it made me laugh and I posted it on like Twitter. I went to sleep two hours.
I woke up and um...
A lot of people were really upset to be honest. I didn't get it. I didn't get it at all.
I'm not the one doing drugs. What the heck did I do?
The meme is so ironic and so stupid talking about like like a boss. I was like
She's still alive. What's the problem if anything, this is a way to snap out of it like yeah, you were an idiot.
So the fact that people came after me, I was just I was really trying to understand why so I read up on addiction
I try to decipher in between the 'you should burn in fire'
messages cause- also a lot of people are saying that I was making fun of mental health.
Which no that wasn't the case at all. I was making fun of Demi and her poor choices.
Cause a lot of people were like 'Well you talked about mental help a few days ago in a video. You're such a hypocrite'
I wasn't doing that. I was making fun of Demi for her poor decision. I realized and I learned that
ostracizing and shaming is the last thing an addict needs to recover cause that's just going to make them more likely to
Relapse and fall back into that behavior. What an addict needs is support and help from
friends and family and I think the public as well. And I also learned that this is her second time
She's dealt with drugs. I just thought I'm really just kicking on someone that's on their complete lowest
I get why people are upset this was wrong for me to do it was a bad thing to do
I don't think it was the worst thing in the world, but it wasn't a nice thing
I can definitely say that. So I thought okay. You know what? I'll just delete it and I'll apologize.
sincerely and
That should be it.
How foolish I am...
I always get people telling me
Stop apologizing. You idiot. What are you doing? You're just making things worse.
Any time you apologize to these people they don't care and they're just gonna shame you even more. I think that's what happened.
BBC posted about it. NBC posted about it. BuzzFeed.
I think the BuzzFeed journalists on her Twitter call it the hell fire or something like that.
Like this is the hell we live in it's like Geez!
But I feel like if I think I've done something wrong...
I shouldn't have the ego or the strategy to just say no, it's better if I don't apologize.
a lot of people were saying that anyone could have posted this meme and no one would bat an eye and I I
Think there is some truth to that
I find it interesting how you have someone that's a role model to a lot of kids you make a message about how
Much better you are now and then you just fall back into the same pain and somehow I'm the bad role model in this
Situation, huh? I'm the villain for just posting a meme about it. It doesn't really make sense to me, and I'm not attacking her
I'm just saying that a lot of people were saying that it's not her fault for her addiction. It's an addiction
She can't control it and I agree
She shouldn't be shamed because of an addiction, but I also don't think babying people will help either
Saying that it's completely out of someone's control is also saying that it's not up to them to recover from it
It's like saying anyone that recovered from addiction didn't do it from their own work
And will it's just a completely random ven, which doesn't make any sense
it's always been a meme on this channel that anything I say will be picked up on the media and
I feel like this was just a testimony of that mean like that's it's a truth essentially anything I say will be
highlighted they will jump on any
reason to
put down my name because if they really cared about these issues about
addiction they would go after the people that that shed a light on it in a positive way not the ones that try and
Ridicule it. I don't know. I don't care moving on
I wasn't gonna talk about this, but it came on today and I watched it
I thought it was so crazy that I had to talk about. It kz9 said there's an interview with Logan Paul and man I
Want to like you Logan I swear but you making it really hard and I find this super interesting cos KZ and Logan are
very similar personalities, they're all about pushing the edge of
Living life to the fullest but their drives are just completely opposite
I think it means falling into the social medium machine
Over the past four years building an audience
Garnering false power through views which equates to money which equates to against success and
Then essentially losing it all
overnight becoming
the most hated man in the world
in the snap of a finger
So the hyperbole every single time the most hated man
Casey asked lo at Logan about this documentary that he's filming and
About the whole incident. Is this a fluff piece to make people feel better about Logan Paul? No, no, not at all this. It's it's
from
Making content throughout the years. I try to be as unbiased as possible and
this
Documentary is going to be as unbiased as possible, but it's me who makes it
Okay, great
I'm sure we very unbiased think people should can or will sympathize with me
Let's be honest Casey. Like let's be honest Casey. I don't know Marcus
I see through your social training Logan
When you put out content like that, do you realize the age of your audience? It's odd because Michael I'm 22 years old
It's not like I don't know why but whenever I see small things like this. I know I'm nitpicking
it feels
Disingenuous is it not?
Premature like it before you can tell a redemption story. There has to be an act of redemption
true
What is the act of redemption bin for Logan Paul? It's it's not been done yet
That's Logan is talking about how this documentary is going to be his redemption story because people love it a redemption story
People told me this
Verbatim so many times that you shouldn't you need to do your redemption
You need to film a documentary people told me this many times
That's how you'll do your comeback and people are telling Logan the same thing and that's why it's doing this documentary
Just like people told me after the wall street journal that I need to do a charity
For Jewish charities or something like that, and I said no
Not because I don't want to because but because it will seem like the most disingenuous thing ever
You're not doing it because you want to you're doing it to save your brand and people are smart enough to see through those things
the rat Casey has
Logan about the red, you know as soon as this forest incident
He tastes the rat or whatever
Why what was up with that? Yeah, the rat was that was me
Becoming obsessed with the idea of being a villain. I just I made the conscious decision
I'm gonna I'm gonna be the guy they think I am I can actually
Relate to Logan here a lot of times
After all the scandals I've been through I question my own morals. I question. Why do I keep ending up in?
These situations and a lot of times I find the answer to be I am genuinely a bad person. I do die
I genuinely think it a lot of times not all the times
But I think the difference is I'm not trying to make other people think
I'm a good person
I can make content and I have been for four years
For four years making people laugh smile believing themselves making them believe that they can accomplish their goals
Even if they're from a small town in, Ohio, I've been making videos for eight years
I just want to show people that you can make it. Even if you're just from a small town in Sweden
What are you saying to use that same pretext as?
Sort of justification for you know killing a rat or why didn't kill the rat
Just shut up. It doesn't matter at this point don't defend these things. It's the same with me
When I drop the n-bomb
A lot of people were like, he said it to another person and I always want to say no
No one heard me say it, but I'm not gonna use that defense because it doesn't matter
That's not what people took out of it some of the other more controversial sensational things you've done
Yeah, running around Japan wearing silly outfits. Yeah, so that Union sensitive to culture apparently for some reason
Casey calls
Casey calling Logan culturally insensitive. It's the most upsetting thing ever for him. I want to address this cuz
I'm not gonna lie. This is the the hardest thing about all this is I
Think being perceived as culturally insensitive
I'm not gonna lie, but the hardest thing out of all this it's the fact that you just called me
culturally insensitive
That's okay I are we expected to believe that or
As far as the outfits go they were on sale at a store the outfits were on sale on their store so then it's okay
Right next to the temple that we were at
For tourists do we not buy the outfits? Maybe he just doesn't understand what it is. There's a difference between culturally insensitive and
insensitive, but it also doesn't matter and you don't seem to understand why one is offensive anyway, so
I'm vegan. Now I
Think the most important thing to take out of this video is this I'm vegan now
Why do you think you being vegan is relevant to anything doing what you want to do to achieve your goals
Which is all like I said, it's always been that but all that stuff is overlooked
When you make mistake, or I can agree again with Logan here. He's done good
I mean, I don't agree with it, but he thinks he's done good like inspiring kids and I can relate to that
I think I've done a lot of positive for in with my channel as well that never gets highlighted
But I don't feel the need to constantly tell people like I'm a good person. Look I do it done all these things
I don't know these charities. I don't know these things. Look I'm a good person. That shouldn't be your mission to keep reminding people
so then Logan talks about how it led up to all this scandal like he was just
Constantly making videos and not thinking what he was doing. We got so caught up in
Creating that we did not stop to think about what we were making and whether or not it was right
Because it you make it you put it out
We were on autopilot essentially which is it's it's extremely dangerous when you're broadcasting to an audience of five to seven million people every day
And so there was no thinking there was it was create content create content create content not okay
Hey, take a step back. Slow down breathe. Do you believe that or is that bullshit?
Because if that's if that mission is the same as this this momentum this autopilot
Where's the distinction between wanting to do good and wanting to you know, looking for sensationalism that will drive clicks?
I'm not I'm not sure I understand the question
That's such a great question I'm not I'm not sure I understand Chris. Hey, this is too much of a mumbo-jumbo
He's saying that if you're just on autopilot, and you're not thinking about what you're doing, how can they you say?
That you care about spreading a positive message and not just caring about sensationalism. I understand I understand
Okay, I can go on pick details whatever you should watch you interview it's interesting a lot of people gave Casey
Or doing this. I think it's good to create a
Dialogue it's a shame how people are so militant towards people. They don't like that. They won't even talk to them
Because that's really how you create division more than anything, which is leads to more hate
I think is he's doing a noble thing. But the final point I find hilarious because Casey praises Logan's
Anti-suicide video that the video he did after the whole thing and the response from Logan
It's just that video. I think had a very important message behind. It was a I liked that video
I tweeted that I liked that video I get for it
but did it show you sort of the
Demonstrate to you that your channel is capable of so much more
And your reach is capable and your voice is capable of so much more than just in socialism views. Yes
Did it change you away from?
Sensationalism and views that what is a question his answer. It's it's the most viewed suus anti-suicide
PSA ever. It's the most
viewed ever
I am so great. I
Have the most viewed PSA anti-suicide video ever. I don't
Really want Lowen to come back but I don't think he can until he's completely honest
Because people are constantly going to be skeptical
especially at this point
I think this entire interview Logan is trying to give the answer that he thinks KZ wants and my tip for Logan
unsolicited advice would be
Question yourself why these?
Titles are important to you. Oh, I'm vegan or you can't call me culturally insensitive and why you care that your video?
Anti PSA has the most views why is that important to you?
And I'm asking you right honestly
Is it to reach more people or is it because you like things to be big because we've seen only evidence for that
So far, so that's all people are gonna see your intention might be different, but I doubt it
Next news twitch added gifts is that in gifts? That's crazy
Alright, we're out of time